Oh you mean the Golden Globes I haven't
even thought about it I've not thought
about it Viola Davis isn't sure whether
or not she'll attend the Golden Globes
in January if she's nominated for her
performance in the woman King the
actress shared her thoughts on the
controversial ceremony while stepping
out at the Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences annual Governor's
Awards in La alongside husband Julius
tennen I know that Brendan Fraser you
know opted out but
I don't know it's up in the air I yeah
it's up in the end all of us have to do
more work that's right when especially
when it comes to equity equality all of
us need to do more work in terms of the
films that are produced in terms of what
we see in terms of what we invest in
Jamie Lee Curtis also discussed the
upcoming Golden Globes and whether the
organization has done enough to improve
its diversity over the past 12 months
it'll never be enough
it's impossible to have it ever be
enough but it's getting better and and I
think that's just the message is that
we're growing and we're learning and
we're talking and in that I think we are
making strides and
you know as we say in
recovery more will be revealed Brendan
Frazier recently revealed that he does
not plan on attending the Golden Globes
if nominated for his performance in the
whale in 2018 the actor accused then
president of the Hollywood Foreign Press
Association Philip Burke of sexually
assaulting him in a new interview with
GQ Brendan said I have more history with
the Hollywood Foreign Press Association
than I have respect for the Hollywood
Foreign Press Association no I will not
participate